WIM LELER: Welcome to
the Developer Show.
I'm Wim Leler.
We're here at Dart
Conf in Los Angeles.
And this is Jacob Richman.
JACOB RICHMAN: Hi,
I'm a developer
on the Dart team in Seattle.
And I focus on developer
tools for Flutter.
WIM LELER: So can you tell
us what the inspector is?
What does it do?
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah,
so the inspector
lets you answer
questions about how
your application is working.
It lets you explore
an application
and really see how
it all ties together,
how it connects from the
device to the widget tree,
to your source code, and makes
all those connections really
quick and easy to follow and
something that we can only
do because of how
Flutter is structured.
WIM LELER: So what
was the motivation
for doing the inspector?
JACOB RICHMAN: So
the motivation is,
because Flutter handles
the whole UI stack,
from the widgets to
rendering, on its own,
rather than relying on native
widgets in iOS or Android,
we really needed to provide
our own inspector tool,
because we can't
depend on native tools
on the platform working for us.
WIM LELER: So can you tell us
about some of the challenges
working on the inspector?
JACOB RICHMAN: So one
of the challenges--
all your UI is to find
in Dart code instead
of some intermediate
markup language.
So this means to write a
really good inspector tool,
we have to really
understand Dart code.
We can't get by
just understanding
some much simpler SML format.
WIM LELER: So can you talk about
the characteristics of Flutter
that made it different to
work on this than other tools?
JACOB RICHMAN: So in Flutter,
everything is a widget.
You have this big
tree of widgets
that describe your application.
And that's great for us, because
it means most of the questions
you care about as a
user using the inspector
are answered by
the widgets tree.
But it means we also have
to be really smart about how
we display the tree and how
we let you navigate back
and forth between the device and
the widget tree in your source
code, because otherwise it
could be too difficult for you
to find where you want to go.
WIM LELER: So what were
some of the reasons for not
using more traditional
tools, like what
are used on Android and iOS?
JACOB RICHMAN: So the normal
tools in Android and iOS
couldn't really tell you much
useful about your application.
They'd just be able to say,
oh, there's one big component.
That's your entire application.
That's really all they know,
because Flutter is fully
owning the whole
UI stack, instead
of trying to provide polyfills
over top of native components
on one platform or another.
WIM LELER: So when is this
going to be available?
JACOB RICHMAN: So
you can use it now
in the latest version of
IntelliJ, the IntelliJ Dart
plug-in that just was released.
And some of the
features we talked about
will require Dart
2.0, because they're
ones where we've taken advantage
of new features in Dart 2.0
to really be able to track
where your widgets were created,
which provides some
of the really deep
linking back and forth between
the widget tree and your source
code.
WIM LELER: Thank you very
much for talking to us.
This was very enjoyable.
JACOB RICHMAN: Thank you.
WIM LELER: And thank
you for watching.